um i think with any when you're going to
a startup i mean when i joined we were
about 100 people and we scaled to like 2
000 in two years so it was that crazy
hockey street growth period where it's
very aggres like aggressive you know
like
midday targets daily targets weekly talk
it was just it was really intense
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
this one is all about sharing meet
rajdeep gaher
founder of co-creations rajdeep is the
founder of co-creations
a venture builder that consults with
corporates and funds to build and grow
internal ventures
clients have included pe funds ebay and
bank of america and merrill lynch
co-creations also incubates disruptive
live work and e-commerce concepts
these include viva house an innovative
co-living venture and winged cosmetics a
beauty brand
previous to this rajdeep joined wework
as an early employee
and led the european rollout from 2014
launching the market in london
and the netherlands she started her
career on a trading floor in london
following a degree from the london
school of economics raj deepika here
welcome to 20 minute leaders
great to be here something to do in
lockdown
something awesome in london we're going
to have so much fun in these 20 minutes
your
journey all the way from being in the
financial industry
after london school of economics all the
way to you know going
into a barclays and being an
entrepreneur at ebay
and then going to we work as an early
employee and leading expansion within
europe which i can't wait to hear all
about
and then bank of america room uh founder
of viva house and
uh co-creations and this idea of
co-living and co-working
as a concept and as an involving
industry that obviously
is impacting all of us and is impacting
the future
and so that was as much talking as i'm
going to do this whole a conversation
tell me a little bit about yourself but
before talking professionally
i have to ask about you know your
ability to deadlift 100 kilograms
because
i'll never get to that level tell me
about that yeah
to to be honest um this was after i left
uh wework uh working a crazy startup
life
where you were pretty much you know
eating out three times a day
i put on a lot of um weight and so i'm
quite extreme
and so when i left uh the first thing i
done was just get a personal trainer
and we used to have like three sessions
a week and he was completely
militant like he scared me like i
i before this was like i don't need a
trainer i'm so self-motivated
but this guy was on another level and um
yeah he really pushed me to the limit
because i've been saying to him for ages
like oh i don't think i need to train
with you i'm fine you know i know what
i'm doing um and yeah he just pushed me
to another level and he was super into
um weight training and then for a brief
couple of months i had this crazy idea
that there was a gap in the market for
like
female indian bodybuilders
so we went down this path just seeing
how strong i was um and it turns out i'm
pretty strong
but yeah these things you need to
maintain so i don't think i can lift
um i can probably lift about half that
much now
you know um which is still all right but
yeah it
we we got to another level which is
great feeling strong is good
i i can't even imagine i think i can
probably lift about a
you know a third of what of what you can
lift so i think that's a
hugely impressive and i love this idea
of you know being fully motivated and
fully
dedicated on an extreme level i i can't
think of anything else that is more
important
to an entrepreneur and obviously with
the journey that you that you've had
before you it's just unbelievable and i
can totally see that mindset
tell me a little bit about your
trajectory because you're starting off
in the financial industry and then
you're moving towards
you know entrepreneurship and towards
this co-working co-living idea so tell
me about that
yeah so i think a lot of life and
business and opportunity
is about timing and suddenly through my
career
it was always really motivated by
intuition
and i think i have good intuition
intuition i think ultimately comes from
experience like an observation of the
world it's not just some like
internal thing it's something that you
get a sense of by
observation and experience so i've
always trusted my intuition
i spent some time in finance i done the
classic you know study
economics analysis um all my peers went
into
finance investment banking or trading
but i just really didn't enjoy it
um and i had thought this was the beacon
um of success but when i got to it i was
like
geez like three years doing the same
thing and then you get a promotion and
like
how can i run like this is just way too
slow
uh and i just wasn't really inspired by
anyone around me at the same time timing
um was telling me the same thing because
timing when i graduated it was
after the last um crash uh yet at the
same time there was like every article
was about london which is where i was
living creating this whole like silicon
ecosystem so looking around about to
challenge the west coast
um and i just thought wow this is like a
new thing
that's up and coming our government
seems to be pumping like
hundreds of millions if not billions
into this new kind of
emergence of the technology space maybe
it's a good time to explore it
and so yeah that that was kind of how it
started
right so you're you're getting into this
industry you're realizing okay
what i'm hearing from you is that it was
the more of the walking versus the
running which really correlates back to
this idea
behind you know the crazy fitness
motivation
so you so you find entrepreneurship
without within ebay tell me
about this this notion of
entrepreneurship within an organization
because then you went and you did
something similar also with bank of
america right
yeah yeah so it was um so i
i the first job that i had was for a
startup um
after finance i mean and it was a real
startup job so
startup pay after being paid in finance
was like chalk and cheese um i
definitely wasn't doing it for the money
and quite frankly
um the job was great i learned so much
we were building like
a version of airbnb airbnb wasn't even
in europe at the time and it was a
rocket internet venture that i was
working with
so you know really aggressive like we
had a lot of traction very quickly so i
learned a lot but um
i just wasn't being paid enough to even
like cover
like basic um you know rent lifestyle
uh which really frustrated me so again
it was it was it was kind of
stemming from frustration and then i
just thought oh timing
again intuition again there's a lot of
talk in the market about corporate
innovation like this seems to be the
next big thing and hey
i've worked for like one corporate and
i've worked for one startup
surely you know enough about both to
kind of position myself
to know about this thing that is
corporate innovation
um and so i had this job in a startup
and i'd also had this like crazy
transitional
job uh after coming back from travel so
i left finance i went traveling for six
months
um pretty much spent a lot of the money
i've been invited
came back and i was like i have
literally raj you have
three months to get a job like you have
to get a job in three months otherwise
you have to move back home with your
parents but i did not want to do
um so three months and it was literally
like
if you don't get something good you just
have to take something so i didn't get
anything good within that three months
it was
bad time in the market it was not the
best time for grads to get jobs
especially grads who would like
said screw it to their last kind of role
and so the job that i got at that time
before i joined the startup
was actually a job really mostly based
on commission and it was like the movie
boiler room
if you've seen it where i was tasked to
make like
80 to 100 cold calls a day to try to
sell a
conference um for 35 000 pounds which is
about 50 000
on the phone through a cold call and you
know
when i started this role i was like this
is not for me i'm such an introverted
person like
like you know this is really difficult
but i actually ended up making a few
sales and it taught me the art of
selling
um and before that i don't think i was a
great sales person i was quite quiet i
was the analytical word i would like get
stuff done but
picking up the phone was like a scary
thing but that was the best training
ever so that followed by the startup
just gave me this level of confidence i
guess to just
literally pick up the phone so when i
had this idea of
maybe i can position myself in corporate
innovation literally all i done was pick
up the phone so i like started looking
for people
companies that i could get in touch with
as well as like a bunch of different
recruiters
a bunch of people in the startup space
and just thought okay let me see if
i can find an opportunity um and so
through that i got a contact at ebay and
i learned that they were trying to set
up a new
team like a new ventures team which is
all about creating startups
and so because i was introduced to them
and they were a new team they didn't
really have
systems in place they wanted to bring me
on board
like on contract for this new team which
meant that i had to set up a company for
them to hire me like they couldn't hire
me as an employee basically because it
was such a new thing and it was a new
team and they were kind of setting up
themselves
so i was like great um so now i need to
set up a company
so i can work with you guys and so
that's really how it all started and i
think it was about 23
at the time or so so i was like okay
cool now i need to let up how to set up
a company
um so may as well brand it because
they're a client of mine right
and and so that and it kind of went from
there because i was like okay if i can
say i've got ebay as a client
i know how to pick up the phone sure i
can get more clients um
so it it yeah and so i went down that
path for
worked with them for a few years and at
the same time started really um
getting into the london startup
ecosystem
working with a lot of startups
networking
people in the space so i made like got
some kind of mentors who are in venture
capital started telling me about other
good startups
i had a really awesome lady who was a
mentor and she was like she's like a top
um
now female venture capitalist in in
europe and she was also like mentoring
or teaching um a course at ucl on
entrepreneurship
so she got me into kind of mentor there
and she was then the one who told me
like hey raj like you've been doing this
consulting for a few years and at that
time i was also like
i was kind of like a bit out
not out of my depth but like how do you
scale a consulting business right like i
had a few people doing bits of work for
me
you get more clients you get more people
to kind of outsource the work to
um but it i i'd kind of realized it
wasn't scalable and all these startups
and venture capitalists i'm speaking to
all about like scalability you know like
automation and scalability so i was like
well consulting isn't really a scalable
business
um and i wanted to just learn more uh
because the rate at which we were
growing ventures at ebay was so slow
compared to like what i was seeing
external startups do
so yeah the advice was why don't you go
and join a cool startup
and through my network i got recommended
to kind of look at this company
who was nothing at the time they didn't
even have you know a round of funding on
crunch base called wework
nothing nothing meaningful i mean the
ceo at the time interviewed me
his name was chris and i remember asking
oh do you do you guys have any funding
because you know
you're trying to hire me for expansion
like the do you guys have money to
expand into europe and he was like i
assure you we do but i can't disclose it
um and yeah after that they came out
with all the press of all the funding
after i joined
so i joined again it was based on
intuition recommendation
incredible meeting yeah a guy for lunch
who became my boss who i thought was
just awesome
um and a desire to learn i think that's
that's incredible i think that
what i'm still uh stuck on and inspired
by this idea that this notion that at 23
years old
you already had the opportunity to go
into finance you had the opportunity to
realize that it's not going to fulfill
your passion
and your goal and to transition into you
know
consulting and sales and the this
importance of branding and finding a gap
in the market saying okay well there's
corporates
there's startups and then there's these
people that that
understand you know the balance of them
and how i can go and integrate that into
a big corporation
and to creating a branding for this
consulting business to understand the
limitations of scalability
of a business to going into a company
this is things that you know these are
things that people don't realize you
know in decades of workings i think
i've never thought about it like that
like how you just put it well
so you're gonna have to listen to this
episode later and you're gonna see how
how crazy it sounds and how awesome it
is
and how inspiring it is and so now this
entrance into we work this tiny startup
that nobody yet hears about
you're helping them run their sales and
expansion within
europe utilizing i guess a lot of the
skills you you had when you did cold
calls for these conferences
and tell me about your understanding
from that point into the co-living and
co-working space
yeah so you know we work with it was a
new thing
um co-working at the time it was really
waving the first flag
and there were a lot of companies that
came out after but this notion of
disrupting the most
traditional industry which is real
estate and in moving from being about
this like
dry boring asset where no one really
cares about what goes inside
happens inside because it's all about
you know the value of just the outfit to
actually it's all about what goes on
inside and how do we make
places where people spend most of their
day working really inspiring
and engaging and what i realized is just
how much of an impact
these environments have on people's
daily rights so if you're talking about
impact like how to make
impact well there's not anything more
impactful you can do than create an
environment where someone spends you
know eight nine
hours of their day and that's the same
with like co living co-working
you you are improving or enhancing the
experience of something that
arguably has the largest impact on
someone's life
um because they're spending so much time
there and it affects their experience of
you know their day-to-day and that's
what i found um
really enchanting let's say and also the
physicality of it
by which i mean when you are in an
operating real estate business
there is very little time you spend
sitting on a chair or in front of a desk
you are always running around and i like
that like i
liked kind of being on the run right
so to sing i love that so you're in
wework you're
there for a few years and you have
enough instead into this industry where
you're starting your own companies
around it both co-living
with viva house and with co-creation
tell me a little bit about this decision
to
spin off into something of your own and
how you're viewing now yourself as a
part of this ecosystem
yeah so i got to the point um i think
with any when you go into a startup i
mean when i joined we were
about 100 people and we scaled to like 2
000 in two years so it was that crazy
hockey street growth period where it's
very aggres like aggressive you know
like
midday targets daily targets weekly
target it was just it was really intense
no regrets but it was on another level i
didn't see my family i didn't see anyone
i just
worked um learnt a lot from it but i i
was really burnt out after two years
and also i just noticed this opportunity
in the market where then everyone else
was starting to think hey let's do our
own operational real estate businesses
or private equity funds
you know financial markets everyone was
waking up to this
this kind of new right space uh and i
thought well the easiest thing i can do
is instead of a lot of people coming and
saying hey raj come and set up a
business for us
i thought why not just pivot my
consulting business
into focusing on operational real estate
which is basically what i done and then
got a few
clients off the back of that so and it
became a great income stream
and i i didn't initially when i started
viva house to take external funding
so i thought if i can have the income
stream from the consulting coming in
i can kind of incubate self-incubate
um via the house which was it really
started as a passion project and desire
to
solve what i saw to be the fundamental
root issue which was
affordability of housing and i couldn't
see any co-living companies really
tackling that right and so where are we
headed
we you know with all of this this idea
of co-living co-working obviously i
think that where the point in time where
you know co-working is pretty much a
part of every uh
tech ecosystem in the world i'm sitting
in a co-working space right now
and you probably pretty much every
street at least in tel aviv and
political new york you have co-working
and i know i know that in london as well
where are we headed in terms of also
co-living this idea that
we will have these shared experiences
that are much more meaningful compoundly
than the intimate experiences we could
have only pretty much with ourselves and
the people though that we see
every single day so what what where are
we headed with this
well i think you know the pandemic has
it's been really interesting for the
whole space you know because again
you could say arguably about five years
ago fundamentally people whose way
of working and living changed because
the way people were spending them time
changed the emergence of co-working
co-living i kind of call it now like
1.0 and now we're almost like version
2.0
because after the pandemic everything is
changing again and i think we're gonna
see more tighter linkage between
um working and living because i mean
take
case in point the uk where i'm now the
majority of people have been working
from home
for the last 11 months and after 11
months
that becomes a pretty entrenched pattern
it's hard to zap people out of it so
then it's
like how do we build mechanisms around
this what are people doing well a lot of
people
have given up their city pad on a
12-month 24-month contract in the city
and now so when they want to go into the
city are maybe looking for something for
a couple of months so i think there's
going to be
um you know a boom in in the service
department
slash co-living um market for
more flexible living and tied to that
there's going to be the sense of like
where you live you should have an
effective means to work
right so i think that's going to be a
huge trend and also i think there's
going to be a great trend for um
you know pent up demand for travel and
co-living co-working experiences abroad
because a lot of companies are now
introducing flexible working policies
to get some people back into the office
but when they the kind of carrot and
stick approach come back to the office
the majority of the time but hey
we'll let you work from a different
country if you like for three to four
months of the year
so it creates another paradigm of like
opportunity
right and i think that what this whole
thing is touching on it pretty much is
this idea of connectivity
and you know the this notion this
age-old notion that home is where the
heart is
well that really is the case you know
starting i think as we come out of this
pandemic
hopefully soon is this idea that you
know really right now we've been forced
to make every home and office and every
office and home
and and obviously these co-living and
co-working environments are just going
to help support that
because we're not i don't see us ever
going back i see us moving forward
and the real solution here is these
spaces which which make us feel at home
wherever we are and which deep i i
really want to thank you for taking the
time to be here i think your journey is
uh amazing i think it seems completely
inspiring and i'm
especially inspired by the lessons that
you've uh taught yourself
over over the time and how you acted
upon that intuition
and that understanding uh whether it's
you know consciously or not this
now looking back and i at least from
this conversation i can form a pretty
linear path i'm saying yes now it makes
perfect sense why she did
a leading to be leading to c obviously
at the given time it might not make that
much sense but
but i'm very inspired by your intuition
and your
courage to go and just act upon it so
thank you for
uh for sharing with me your story and
before we leave i have to ask you for
the most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um ambitious uh
tenacious and hopefully kind i love that
i love that
thank you so so much stay safe and stay
healthy and i can't wait to one day
live in one of your co-living spaces and
work around the core
thank you very much thanks so much
michael take care thank you